LAURENCE MORONEY: With the
announcement of Kotlin,
it's an exciting time to
be an Android developer.
Today on "Coffee
with a Googler,"
I'm chatting with one of the
people who made it happen,
Jeffrey Van Gogh.
So one of my favorite moments
at Google I/O this year
was when we did
that Kotlin reveal,
and it was the
Android lock screen.
And they carved out the K in
it, and the crowd went crazy.
And Jeffrey, I know you're
one of the guys behind this.
What was it like to
bring Kotlin to Android?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Oh, it was amazing.
I joined Android
Studio two years ago.
And of course, we
talked out to customers.
And we started hearing that
people thought that Java
was not really moving forward.
They wanted to get more
modern language features.
And so as we started
looking into that,
one of the things that came
up are these people really
like Kotlin.
And so about a year ago,
I started playing with it.
And it's so much
more productive.
It's so much fun.
I had cut a lot of the things
that I really liked about C#,
but still a lot of the
compatibility with existing
Java libraries.
And then they added a
whole bunch of new things
on top of it as well.
And so it just makes
programming a lot more fun.
And so we need to get this
into our customer hands.
And so the weeks, months,
leading up to I/O,
we had a lot of
talks with JetBrains
to see if we could get it done.
And we got it done.
And people really are excited,
and we are very excited.
Of course, it's just a start.
We need to do a lot
more hard technical work
to really make it a first
class language for Android.
And there's a lot more to
come over the next year.
I think we can do a
lot of cool things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So why Kotlin?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
It's a fun language.
It's really fun to program.
It's very little code you have
to write, compared to Java,
you have to implement the whole
class with fields, getters,
setters, hash codes, equals.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Most of my
bugs are in POJOs like that.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Oh, yeah.
In Kotlin, it's
one line of code.
And there's many more
examples like that.
It's just a fun,
productive language
that makes your whole
programming experience so much
easier.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And can I still
be productive as an
Android developer
if I'm using, like, third party
libraries and open source Java
stuff?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Oh, absolutely.
Kotlin interrupts
with Java very simply.
They both compile
to Java bytecode,
which we then compile
to Dalvik bytecode
for running on Android.
And so it runs
the same on the OS
and on the source language side.
It has a really good interrupt
between Java and Kotlin.
You can call Kotlin from
Java, Java from Kotlin.
You can even have inheritance,
where your Java class
is extended by Kotlin class and
extended by Java class again.
It works very smoothly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And then from a tooling
perspective in Android Studio,
do I get, like, file new Kotlin?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Oh, yeah.
You can, either in existing
project, add a new Kotlin file,
or when you start a
new project, you just
check the box and
the wizard saying,
I want Kotlin enabled to
already create the default
activities in Kotlin source.
And it will set all the
settings in your Kotlin plugin,
create a plugin.
It's a very smooth experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
You know, this actually,
really, reminds me
of when Swift first came out.
And there were a lot of
Objective-C developers,
and then Swift came out.
But it had that level
of compatibility
that, as a Swift
developer, I could
consume Objective-C libraries
and that kind of stuff.
And then Swift really took off.
So hopefully, Kotlin
will take off,
and Android in the same way.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Yeah, I hope so.
I love the language.
So I'd definitely like
to see it succeed.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, so
if I'm an Android developer,
and I've been using
Android Studio for a while,
and if I've got a number
of third party libraries
in Java that I'm using,
can I continue to use those
if I'm using Kotlin?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Yeah, absolutely.
So the way that Kotlin
works, it compiles down
to Java bytecode, which is
the same thing that the Java
compiler does.
And then we take our tools--
the dexer that takes
the Java bytecode
and converts it to
Dalvik bytecode.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: And so for the
Android OS, it's just the same.
It's just Dalvik bytecode.
It doesn't know any different.
And so Kotlin, actually, has
a really good interrupt story
with the Java code.
And you can actually call
Kotlin code from Java,
and Java code from Kotlin.
And you can have inheritance
hierarchies in between.
And it just works fine.
Because in the end,
it's all bytecode.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
So now, like I've only
used Java in Android.
It's on my to-do
list to learn Kotlin.
But why all the love for Kotlin?
Why this language in particular?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: So I think
if you look at the language,
it's not a particularly
innovative language.
There's not a lot of
new research going on.
But they didn't
set out to do that.
They wanted it to be
a productive language.
So they looked at a
lot of other languages
that have a lot of
modern features.
And they figured, how can
we interrupt this with Java,
without having to
break two worlds,
and make developers
more productive?
I think the area that
they are more innovative
is that they started
from the tool side.
Most languages,
they start, and they
write a standard compiler,
batch compiler, which
takes source input,
and run a command line,
and produce output.
JetBrains is a tool company.
And they started, like, how do
we do this in the [INAUDIBLE]??
How do we make sure
that refactoring works?
How do we ensure that
static analysis works?
I believe that they had the
frontend working before they
had the backend working.
So it's a very
different mindset.
And I think the real innovation
area is in the tooling.
And that's why you see that
people are so productive.
The tooling works very
closely with the language,
and that makes you
more productive
than in other languages.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
your role in Google
is you work on the compiler
and the compilation.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yes.
So I run several teams in
Android CO, and one of them
is the compiler team.
So we used to have the
Jack compiler, which
converts Java source
code to Dalvik bytecode.
And earlier this year, we
announced that we are no longer
investing in that.
And so we started investing
a couple of tools.
We were doing Java 8
desugaring for people
who want to use Java
8 language features.
So if you say, Kotlin
isn't my thing,
you can still use all
the new Java 8 features
in Android security space.
We're also investing
in the dexer.
So the dexer converts your Java
bytecode to Dalvik bytecode.
And we're doing more and
more optimizations there,
making sure we use smaller code.
We're also doing
work to make sure
it works very
optimally with Kotlin,
so that we can make sure that
your debugging scenarios work
correctly, et cetera.
And then the other
thing I'm working on
is I'm working together
with JetBrains on the Kotlin
Language Committee
to make sure that we
evolve the language correctly.
And so that mainly focuses
around breaking changes
and deprecation policies.
We want to make
sure that Kotlin is
a language that people can
depend on for many years
to come.
And so there shouldn't
be any surprises
that the features
no longer work when
you want to compile your
app two years forward.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
So you're part of the language
committee steering Kotlin.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Yeah, correctly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So we're not just
investing in Kotlin
being part of our tools,
but we're really
heavily invested
in the language itself.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yeah.
We announced at Google I/O there
is a foundation being formed.
And as part of that,
there is a committee
with one person from JetBrains,
one person from Google,
and an independent.
And so we are looking
at the language
and making sure that
we don't break people
as we are building
new, cool features.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Excellent.
That sounds really cool now.
The one thing I hear about
Kotlin always is that it's fun.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yeah, it is.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's fun to play with.
What makes it so much fun?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: So for
me, it's particularly fun.
I've been doing programming
languages for my whole career.
I have been working on compilers
and static analysis tools
for 15 years.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
So I always like
to see what cool things people
do with language and the tricks
you can do with it.
But I think even for people
who are just writing programs
for a living, not necessarily
programming language geeks,
it makes it a lot
more fun because you
don't have to write all
the boilerplate code.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Java is very verbose.
When you write a--
let's say you have a class
that's describing a customer.
You have to write all the fields
and all the getter and setter
methods, you're get
hash code, the equals.
In Kotlin, that's
just one line of code.
And it will generate
all the boilerplate
and make sure it is correct.
And so that's just one example.
There are so many things
where they made sure
that you have to write less
code, that it's less buggy.
You don't have to worry as
much about null pointer issues
because they track all the
null pointer information
and give you compiler
errors if you mess it up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And just going back
to that moment at I/O
when we announced it,
it was such a surprise,
not just for people outside
of Google, but many of us
inside of Google.
And it's like I sit really
close to you here at Kirkland,
and I had no idea.
I was sitting in the audience,
and it just blew my mind
that you're supporting Kotlin.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: We really
wanted to keep it secret.
We didn't want it to leak.
We wanted a big surprise.
And also, we needed
a time to make sure
that everything went through.
We wanted to make sure we had a
good deal set up that protects
the future of the language.
And so we wanted to make sure
that we did everything right
before we announced it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
was such a surprise,
but such a great surprise.
Because social media lit
up, as you probably saw,
at I/O. What's the
feedback been like?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: A
lot of people love it.
We heard a lot of
people saying, well,
I was worrying that I had
to go argue with my manager.
But now that Google supports
it, it's a done deal.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's always good
when we prevent people
arguing with their managers.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yeah, it is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: As
a manager yourself,
I'm sure you appreciate it.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yeah, although
a good technique argument--
I like to have those.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'll
bear that in mind.
So the feedback was
generally very positive.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yeah.
I think there was some
worry about people
thinking that now we're no
longer investing in Java.
But as I said, we just added
a Java 8 support to enrich CO.
And we'll keep
investing there as well.
We understand that
it's not for everybody.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
So we fully plan
to invest in Java
functionality as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if I'm a
new developer, and I'm getting
started, and I'm
starting with Android,
and I've heard all about
Kotlin and how much fun it
is, how would I get
started building this?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: So
it's actually really easy
to get started because it's
not a either/or choice.
You don't have to say, well,
I'm going to either choose
Java or Kotlin.
You can just take an
existing Java project
and add one Kotlin file and
write one function in Kotlin
and keep the rest
of your app in Java.
And everything keeps working.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Or
you could go as extreme
as writing your
whole app in Kotlin
and never look again at Java.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, nice.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: So you can
go anywhere in that spectrum.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
in Android Studio, will
my file new project experience
other Kotlin templates?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yes.
So either you can-- if you
have an existing project,
you can just add
a new Kotlin file.
Or if you want to
start with some project
from scratch, in the wizard,
there will be a new check box.
And I noticed you have 3.0 and
above, it says enable Kotlin.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: And it will
do all the work of adding Kotlin
to your Android griddle file
to load the Kotlin plugin.
It will also create the first
activity in Kotlin source.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
So then if I just want to
get started with Kotlin,
Android Studio seems
to be the way to go.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yep, yep.
And then if you're not
sure if you want to try it,
there's also, on
kotlinlang.org, there
is an online "hello
world" sandbox.
And you can play there as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, so the sandbox--
I can start typing code in
my browser and testing it
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yep.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And this is
on the Android developers site?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: No,
it's on kotlinlang.org.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, I see, OK.
But the Android Studio I get
from the Android developers,
right?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
I want to get started,
it's worth playing
kotlinlang.org.
And I go to
developer.android.com
to download Android Studio.
Cool.
And is there any
words of advice you'd
give to developers getting out
and starting with this stuff?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH:
Just try it out.
It's so much fun.
You'll realize that
you don't have to write
all your boilerplate code.
And coding becomes
so much more fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds great.
So thank you so much, Jeffrey.
Thanks a lot.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee With a Googler,"
and for Jeffrey being our guest.
If you are like me,
and you are just
itching to get
started with Kotlin,
we've heard that's
the way to do it.
The kotlinlang.org, right?
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Yep.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And also
download Android Studio.
And you can just do
file new experience
and use the templates
and just start coding.
So I'm really looking forward
to seeing the kind of things
that you're going to build.
So thank you very much.
Thanks again, Jeffrey.
JEFFREY VAN GOGH: Thank you.